بابا ماما ..بابا ماما
بفمي شيءٌ يؤلمني
يحفر في أسناني حُفَرا ألم ٌ وجعٌ سني آي
آي يا أسناني
وأحسُّ بأسناني جمرا
آي آي أسناني
خدّي ماما أكبرُ وأكبرْ
في المرآةِ أراهُ احمرْ بقعٌ في الأسنانِ وحفرةْ
آي آي أسناني
بابا ماما ..بابا ماما
بفمي شيءٌ يؤلمني
يحفر في أسناني حُفَرا ألم ٌ وجعٌ سني آي
آي يا أسناني
قالت أمي هيّا إبنيْ
آي آي أسناني
دعنّا نذهب عندي طبيبْ
قال طبيبي لا لا تبكِ السوسةُ تعمل تخريبْ
آي آي أسناني
بابا ماما ..بابا ماما
بفمي شيءٌ يؤلمني
يحفر في أسناني حُفَرا ألم ٌ وجعٌ سني آي
آي يا أسناني
أكلُ الحلوى باستمرارٍ
أسناني أسناني
للسوسةِ كالحقل خصيبْ
لكن عندي حلٌّ أيضا ودواءٌ للضرس عجيبْ
آي آي أسناني
بابا ماما ..بابا ماما
بفمي شيءٌ يؤلمني
يحفر في أسناني حُفَرا ألم ٌ وجعٌ سني آي
اغسل أسنانك يا ولدي
نعم سأغسلهم
بالفرشاةِ مساءً فجرا
طبعا سأغسلهم
فسترجعُ أسنانُك أقوى وأشد بياضا بل أحلى
آي آي أسناني